if you have ever loved
you would probably have
noticed that many of
their pattern of ripples around their
circumference which have a wavelength of
about one centimeter in this paper we
present an experimental study that
explores the origin and evolution of
these icicle ripples so to do this we
built a tabletop machine for growing
bicycles that allows us to control the
temperature water supply rate and air
motion around the icicle we rotate the
icicle very slowly while it is growing
so we can distribute the water evenly
around the icicle to encourage excess
Emma tree and the rotation also allows
us to image and analyze the different
sides of the icicle here are three
icicles grown under identical conditions
except for the concentration of sodium
chloride dissolved in the water the
movie on the Left shows a distill water
icicle which has a platonic shape with a
relatively smooth surface the movie in
the middle is a nice cold made from a
solution that has only 40 milligrams of
salt per kilogram of water and we can
see that even such a tiny amount of
ionic impurities can produce a clear
regular set of ripples the movie on the
right shows a much more saline icicle
which deviates the furthest away from
both axis symmetry and self-similarity
so using image analysis and four-year
methods we found that growing ripples
are not present on distilled water
icicles even when we saturate the water
with dissolved gases growing ripples are
also not produced when we add Triton
x100 which is a non ionic surfactant
that we use to reduce the surface
tension of the water on the other hand
ripples appear on icicles made from
saline water even at very low
concentrations the ripples on more
saline icicles grow faster to higher
amplitudes
although the ripple amplitude can also
decrease after it has saturated we also
found that at sufficiently low
salinities the growth speed of the
ripples increases
the salt concentration this increase is
roughly logarithmic which is very weak
below about 0.05 a percent the ripples
climb up the ice coat uniformly at a
speed of a few millimeters per hour but
above point oh five eight percent the
ripple motion becomes more nonlinear and
different ripples on the same bicycle
can travel in opposite directions there
have been a couple of theories trying to
explain the formation of icicle ripples
but none of them has considered the
affective impurities which we have shown
experimentally to be the most
significant control parameter in this
problem